yeah you saw that you saw the stance who
was the lady with your your papa
that's his fiancee oh did you roll with
her yeah yeah
she seems cool she's pretty cool yeah
bro that cracked me up with uh
um i knew my dad like my dad would like
get down on the whiskey but i know she
would
she took that [ __ ] to the head i was
like paying attention you weren't paying
attention
i just knew all my whiskey was gone what
your dad left
no don't do it don't do it yeah
shout out
chappelle came through we got the
picture on there your
fans thinks it's cedric the entertainer
yeah everyone says that they thought it
was cedric the entertainer until they
read your caption
yeah we had a lot of people come through
but not cedric then or not cedric
i know that would have been nice did we
email him we should have emailed him
why are you going to be a hard pass from
cedric i think yeah no he come through
he's
amazing i watch his tv show where's that
support
uh there's your papa yeah there he is
yeah i know the shoes bro that's like
one of them old school players they have
like the yo-yo in the club
yes young girls you know why you never
seen a dude walking that's a fat ass
watch he has
oh yeah that's a nick that's a nixon i
don't know what that is i don't know
watson and then didn't he just
get a uh a drop talk too oh yeah a
counterwriter
uh no no he got some cadillac he was
leaving he was like yo i just bought
that new county 76. yeah
like what oh folks i know he was so
funny back there he said uh
he's just so funny he was like you need
any protection i was like uh
yeah he is leaving that they say you
need protection yeah you need a
protection or anything like that
i told him yeah but he ignored me yeah
how about we were uh
he's talking and stevie's taking a
picture and you're all stevie did time
dad
yeah yeah that was the first thing he's
like
yeah he's on february he's like yeah
exactly
[ __ ] and i was like what's the
difference yeah he's like
pedro's more they're nicer they're a
little more luxury they have these boxes
in there yeah yeah there's a little
little
it's a little easier to do time there i
know that he was telling us about his
scar that he had
yeah yeah he said it was his fault yeah
get shanked in prison he's like and i
started it
he's telling me some dude was just
like my dad was so ruthless because i
mean he they gave him a life sentence so
like people that are giving the life
sentence they're just
like there's nothing to live for so
there was some dude i guess in there
and i'm gonna try to tell as best as you
know i could but some dude in there
yeah said what's up to him and he was
like he was the new guy
in there your dad was a new guy oh the
guy the new guy yeah all right and then
my dad's like hey you ain't supposed to
say what's up to me i was like god damn
he got stabbed over that
well so so then he was like man i was
just saying what's up homie i'm just
trying to be cool nah the guy was
generally just trying to be cool
my dad's like nah man you can't say
what's up to me you ain't supposed to
talk to me you earned it right
yeah yeah yeah he goes i don't know you
homie that's how
literally they started throwing up the
gang signs at each other
right he threw up his gangster my dad
threw off his and then uh
he's alright bet i got you so um
my dad and his goons were like waiting
for him like in the mess hall but they
didn't see him around
right and so my dad was like all right
maybe he just
you know maybe we got transferred yeah
maybe he got transferred maybe
yes and then so uh all my dad's goons
like went
like jumped a dude or whatever and my
dad ended up getting like handcuffed
and he was like bleeding he's like man
yeah they gotta arrest both parties
so did they uh took your dad to the
hospital yeah he had to go get operated
on god damn
yeah and he showed me prison sounds
exhausting i know right
let me let's just recap the story new
guy gets the prison
says what's up didn't like what i said
what's up
he went to lunch dad turned around got
stabbed in the stomach
from the new guy away from the stomach
yeah that's stabbed in the stomach
for saying hi yeah was he on the empty
stomach said hi
obviously he was going to help you stomp
it
you got stack you said hi to the wrong
guy wrong guy
well i mean he starts throwing up let's
call it what is sign language
sign language oh i think he's i don't
know what know i'd be sign language
sign language yeah that's sign language
in a sense but that means a lot to
the people that can read the silence
yeah that's what i'm saying how stupid
it is
it's isn't it crazy isn't it crazy it's
just such a because i think my fingers
went in different patterns
it upsets you no that's not what upset
them wasn't the different patterns
well it didn't help them it escalated
yeah it's saying obligated because of
the game
i'm with this team you're with that team
i like the way
and then homeboy got stabbed in the
stomach you're throwing up east side
yeah this is my team you don't like it
this is your team
what are you doing i don't like it i'm
going to stab you in the stomach he
looks so
cool yeah he does dude i don't know what
you did right sign language
like yours i ain't gonna say you look
like my classmate earl when he came in
class
oh don't leave earl alone but no uh it
is crazy
stressful it's stressful yeah you talked
to stevie he said he thrived in it but
again
that's fed yeah i didn't i didn't know
there was that i didn't know there was
like a difference between
i know that i didn't know i didn't know
there's a difference i knew i know
federer you're doing longer times
a little easier and it's for other [ __ ]
and then in
state you got to deal with the gang
activity yeah and the indian county
real problem county well now you're
talking about jail
county jail is where the most violence
happens that's the worst because
everyone's
on edge everyone has anxiety they don't
know where they're going and i'll send
you a picture of him
in prison yo uh my friends when they get
to county
they literally have to call the homies
because there's so many because you have
so many gays
in one austin yeah i don't know who i
would go with
who would look mexican but the whites
aren't going to claim me
yo that's a great question who would you
go with it
because you do look like a double down a
mexican they run like you know that's
probably a good idea
yeah oh yeah as far as using good just
for the best he knew like a mexican
accent
i just wouldn't talk think so oh no i
wouldn't talk
i don't want to give myself up what
would you do
it's just silent mexican what okay it's
just silent mexicans
so i'm i'm i shave my head force get new
tattoos and [ __ ]
we'll be your first time none of your
tattoos are like you don't know what
they are
i'll get an aztec on my neck be sick oh
yeah you want your cobwebs
i mean you have an la one you can
pretend to repeat that's right
yeah yeah
i mean you gotta get it yeah it's gonna
be tough it's gonna be
you guys would definitely do much better
in prison yeah yeah i don't want to go
nowhere near the jail
if i go to jail i'm gonna be somebody
prom date by 12 o'clock oh damn dog wait
[Laughter]
god damn i mean you and your dad look
identical identical yeah
you shaved your head go back soon
the other one yeah think about with the
dif
the different mindset your dad has now
like you never stab a guy from saying hi
dude he is so relieved now like he is
just so
like he loves i mean he loves his life
now yeah he's just so happy like
because i mean i think once he realized
like so much and like when he made it
out
he was just like [ __ ] he goes man i just
want to
i just want to just live my life you
know i'll tell you what bummed me out
this weekend it's like that king bond
[ __ ]
for the listeners
yeah that's depressing you know he's a
famous rapper of chicago
gets shot in atlanta and dies god damn
dude
did she the clips of his friends raiding
his house
he's like best friends raiding his house
well well they said allegedly best
friends though
it's such a shame though and then
there's a video the day before
he's at target with his like little
nephew yeah
going i'm gonna shoot you and he's like
well what do we do with people that
shoot us he talks about what do you do
to a guy if you shot him
it's just that culture is so [ __ ] man
i try to stay away from that
ain't nothing listen my my pops told me
earlier yo like
if you you can get in that gang stuff
you want to but there's only two
outcomes
the cemetery or in jail which one you
want to spend your life in
i say comedy comedy
good for you if my dad didn't study law
and like get himself out yeah he
probably oh your dad is the walking
epitome of abc for life
you love anything does uh show
yes such a 50 cent fan boy
boy how are you no damn they they
arrested a guy
yeah yeah the guy oh they arrest that
guy that's right best case scenario for
him
because they were going to murder him of
course there's video of uh
you know the king von's goons driving to
i think it was new orleans
don't blow on it like that oh that's
what that was
they know they're going to have to they
know they have to keep them in
witness protection i mean not women but
even in jail he's going to be in trouble
right
they got him in isolated they won't be
able to get to him for now
for now until the court yeah until you
get tried for it of course but either
way
it's such a shame man a 22 year old and
he's young did you do
we had a picture he looked like he has
like these little uh florida dreads he's
a young guy tattoos on kingman
no the guy who oh the guy killed him he
got killed i know he's super young so
you know
also rapper 22 22 years old he was in
the video with uh
rondo your listeners might be confused
life's over yeah we need to get
everyone's like what are they talking
about that's him right there
yeah i see you right there
i think i think my my dad was only 22
when he was
uh when he got sentenced to life
yeah i mean he started he started in the
game like early
yeah i think he was like 12. i mean look
and i was like
who i started you guys my brother i was
like it's just such a shame that king
von just couldn't get out it's like all
right you leave
because i guess he has some money i
don't know how much money he was making
it's probably not that much of the music
industry he's making pretty
decent but it's not like you're going to
move your entire family and friends out
of the hood
once you're and then when his rival dies
he
was like man i hope i get to heaven and
kill him up there i was like
but he doesn't make sense he's in yeah
well i don't know it's so stupid yeah
but no i know it
doesn't make sense i don't like talking
about that because like it's a bummer
yeah and then and then this and the same
we'll get off after this but then then
it's such the the [ __ ] up culture then
takashi 69 who had a
beef with king vaughan when they
announced he was dead post emoji
laughing no he didn't yeah he did he did
swear to god i promise why would i make
that up i don't do it yeah i know
a lot of people are hating on him right
now because like right after he was
joking about
king von dying because they had an issue
and then the issue started too with
uh takashi 69's team offered uh
king von money to start a like a like a
fake feud
and king von's like [ __ ] that dude i'm
not doing that and that's when
kash 69 drove to chicago obviously has
more security than god
otherwise you wouldn't make it out alive
and sound cool in chicago and goes to
all the spots it was like pissing on
stuff and
you didn't see no one saying i saw that
video because he's looking at us crazy
keeps you updated huh i remember it was
a video where he was like yo i'm gonna
post this instagram video like i'm out
the brother i'm gonna block on these
chicago streets and they had a video of
him getting in the car
immediately right after that well cause
someone was okay they found out where
you're at they're coming he's like
that's my time later
i got the light ladies
the guy who murdered uh king von le get
to him same like whitey bulger
i made not made but i asked you to watch
black mass when we're in phoenix oh that
was a great nice saturday morning really
let me tell you about ourselves
like damn you've not had chick-fil-a
breakfast i go i haven't chappelle
nicely enough orders chick-fil-a
breakfast with the
texas tom's hot sauce texas pete texas
pete shout out to pete and tom
so we got texas pete hot sauce on the
chick chicken sandwiches
and the biscuit fantastic breakfast with
that jelly so i started educating him on
whitey bulger right got my black belt
whitey baldr i've read seven [ __ ]
books on this guy like you've never seen
black massacre sure have it
i find it on the tv we've rent it we
spent the morning in chick-fil-a
watching [ __ ] black mess
yep it was in chick-fil-a oh yeah
interesting nice little no not in
chick-fil-a oh i thought you were
someone
but think about uh uh door dash prom
code shop but the thing is
uh no delivery freeze for your first
order but the thing is is uh
like whitey bulger right did horrible
[ __ ] he was on the run for i think
fourteen years sixteen fourteen when
they caught him
they caught him in santa monica four
blocks from here up the street
oh yeah that was right up the street off
santa monica here in pacific
so they caught him up the street from
here at an apartment complex so he gets
arrested for
horrible [ __ ] they're transferring him
from one prison another prison
and at the other prison this dude who
just hates snitches and actually worked
for the tally mafia
which whitey bulger [ __ ] over makes
sense
and so he got a hold of him beat him
with a lock and a sock
ripped his eyes and tongue out of his
mouth he was probably dead
he was also 93 when they caught him so
why do bolger kind of won
you're 93 yeah that's that's like that's
living brother well that is true the
goal is
also 93 locked to the face probably the
first hit was
93 he's out he probably got shoved and
died
yeah like that's an initial hit game
like the show
probably like well hold on hold on he
listen that man right you know how old
he was
but he wasn't like but like there's so
like a crispy 93 but the goal is to die
young at an old age
right so he probably was was
no doubt that's a news reporter no no
i'm saying you die young at old
like his spirit is young oh and he's an
old guy yeah he's still old though you
know the body's old
so when you get in the face at 93 it's
like it's not like if
one of us where you hit in the face
where you kind of be able to [ __ ]
fight it like it's
like you're natural i might i say i
might cry you know i'd be like
but i mean it's going to take a lot of
long time the [ __ ] out of you what i'm
saying
so how many hits did he have in him i
bet that first one [ __ ] him up but
they they put they
they destroyed him so bad they said his
face was unrecognizable when they caught
up to him
yeah like they didn't even know don't
look at my face but oh you should
but how about i love it but how about
his main hitman
only got 12 years murdered well over 19
people
but worked with fbi gave up whitey
bulger snitched on him to put him away
and the fbi agent away for 40 years that
dude
right now is probably having coffee at a
cafe in boston
just chilling free yeah and they asked
him they offered him witness protection
he goes
i'm good in boston no he's going to
touch me show enough good in boston
[Music]
isn't that crazy yeah that that just a
straight up bonafide
killer is i mean he's probably retired
now hopefully he's learned from his ways
johnny depp did really good ah that's
right
to me best role you think that's his
best that's my favorite role
really he did really he did really
[ __ ] good still getting that
so good in that the part where he gets
the wife oh my god
yeah i go to my girl all the time she's
like i don't feel good white because why
do bulger
they're at dinner and he's like where's
your wife yeah he has such
anxiety that people can snitch on him
she's upstairs she's sick he's like i'll
go check it out he's like no
no see he goes up there yeah he just
answers really well
she's all i i told you i don't feel good
he's like oh really you know you feel
hot he starts rubbing her head
and he grabs her throat your lymph nodes
aren't swollen so it's
just i don't know you think he's gonna
just that was such a good scene
it's so i do to my girl all the time
she's like i feel sick i start grabbing
you don't feel sick no you lift like i
could feel it
i can feel it yes
because he was doing that to everybody
he was just freaking just going off
shout out to blow blow i never blow oh
he's great
when we go to boston we got to go triple
o's that was white bulger's uh bar which
is still there
according to stevie it's a real [ __ ]
hole but i'd love to get some merch
there if they have it
yeah he looks good too yeah i just think
oh dude he hold up he looks
identical to whitey bulger that's
[ __ ] nuts yeah
that that was that makes me want that
chase do you think that was his last
good role
hell no uh let me see johnny depp movies
because black mask came out like 2014 i
think 2015. i feel like the only thing
he's been in
after that was the uh harry potter
series bam
who's in here that's 1990 the newer ones
oh no
he got fired from that yeah he had to
resign he had to resign
yeah yeah he got fired uh what's his
latest movie though yeah what is let's
go to his imdb
johnny depp's are great by the way he
has a catalog by the way
oh city of lies is a great movie by the
way i never seen that excuse keep going
down
what's that say 10. oh it's just short
it's a video short
pirates of the caribbean dead man no
tails awful 2017.
he's awful alice whirling not great
black mask yeah that's what i got that's
like
hard-hitting film allison he killed that
by the way no not the second one do you
see the second one
the original one was good the second one
that looking through the glass
yeah you give me my [ __ ] money back
you just
yeah the first one's great it was great
so legit i'm surprised
yeah dark shadows fantastic twin jump
jump street fantastic
the one ranger i loved
this one lego movies can't miss the lone
ranger pike's caribbean's
on stranger tides awful rango fantastic
fantastic
i was waiting the music oh yeah
i did a commercial for it bro want to be
a cowboy so bad after that
public enemies legit 109 legit sweeney
todd classic classic
fights caribbean world's end fantastic
dead man's chest fantastic okay keep
going legend of jack's braille fantastic
i'm liking
the video of him holla charlie chalk
factory could have done better but he
was good
he was great okay keep going i'm loving
this one's climbing mexico
hell yeah happily ever pearl great from
hell
fantastic blow top ten talk that talk
shook a lot uh sleepy hollow classic get
it off your chest bro come on brenden
donnie brasco classic didn't see that i
don't know you've seen donnie brasco no
that's a true story too oh wow fellas i
see that wow
what's eating gilbert grape classic oh i
mean
we can watch movies and you know you
guys are edward scissorhands chin's
favorite my favorite i love that then he
got famous from 21 jump street
crybaby tv series that's where they got
that's where they got it from i didn't
know that he was the main
actor on 21 that's where his that's
where he jumped off no pun intended
that was okay well i wish i i wish i'd
got that reference
i love that movie with uh uh jonah and
uh
channing tatum oh yeah i thought it was
the original
movie it was a great movie yeah it was
pretty fun his cameo that's why he's in
hit the camera because he's the original
21 jump street guy what was that when he
was a teenager what was this
he remember he worked for the biker gang
he has the nose oh
d right he did the shot yes yes yes yes
at the end yeah he's right
yeah you're right i apologize how about
stevo how about that when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son